>> Dan: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
"2020 ELECTION."
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN JAPAN
FOR THE G20.
IF HE SAYS ANYTHING WE'LL
BRING IT TO YOU LIVE THIS
HOUR.
SWITCHING GEARS, WE ARE
HOLDING THOSE WHO ABUSE POWER
ACCOUNTABLE, DEMOCRATS AND THE
PARTNERS IN THE MEDIA MOB
CONTINUE TO FUEL MORE MUELLER
MANIA AND IMPEACHMENT
FANTASIES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> LET ME TELL YOU.
WE NEED SOMEONE ON OUR STAGE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE GENERAL
ELECTION WHO KNOWS HOW TO
RECOGNIZE A RAP SHEET WHEN
THEY SEE IT AND PROSECUTE THE
CASE.
>> GOVERNOR INSLEE?
>> THE BIGGEST THREAT TO THE
SECURITY OF THE UNITED STATES
IS DONALD TRUMP.
[APPLAUSE]
>> A PRESIDENT WHO FOUGHT TO
OBSTRUCT THE INVESTIGATION IN
THE INVASION OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
WE MUST BEGIN IMPEACHMENT NOW
SO THAT WE HAVE THE FACTS AND
THE TRUTH AND WE FOLLOW THEM
AS FAR AS THEY GO.
>> Dan: IN THE TWO NIGHTS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC DEBATE THERE IS
NOT ONE QUESTION ON THE DEEP
STATE ON FISA ABUSE, OR USE OF
THE SECRET INFORMANT TO SPY ON
TEAM TRUMP.
JOINING ME IS SARA CARTER, AND
GREGG JARRETT, AND CONGRESSMAN
ANDY BIGGS.
GREGG, TO YOU FIRST.
I THINK THE MUELLER APPEARANCE
ON JULY 17 HAS POTENTIAL TO
BLOW UP SPECTACULAR IN THE
DEMOCRATS' FACE.
>> IT'S A BIG MISTAKE.
>> Dan: HUGE MISTAKE.
ONE OF THE REASONS IS MUELLER
REPORT IS WRITTEN LIKE AN
OP-ED, NOT A SERIOUS LEGAL
DOCUMENT AND HE LEAVES A LOT
OF THINGS OUT.
ONE CONTACTS HE ELECTIONS IS A
RUSSIAN CARVEOUT FOR MANAFORT.
HE WAS A SOURCE FOR THE OBAMA
STATE DEPARTMENT.
INTERESTING POINT TO BRING UP.
NO?
>> YEAH.
HE EITHER CONCEALED IT OR
DELIBERATELY TRIED TO DECEIVE
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
SAME THING WITH THE PROFESSOR
MASOUD.
HE IS NOT A RUSSIAN AGENT AT
ALL AND HE WORKS FOR BRITISH
GOVERNMENT PROBABLY.
AND IN TURN THE AMERICANS AS
WELL.
HE TAKES JOHN DOWD'S TELEPHONE
MESSAGE AND HE EDITS IT DOWN
TO MISREPRESENT THAT.
ANOTHER PLACE I FOUND HE
COMPLETELY MISREPRESENTED AND
INVENTED A CONVERSATION
INVOLVING PAPADOPOULOS AND
MASOUD.
HE DOESN'T SOURCE IT.
HE JUST MADE IT UP AND PLUCKED
IT FROM HIS OWN IMAGINATION.
SO THE REPORT IS FRANKLY
DISAPPOINTING IN SO MANY WAYS.
DISORGANIZED.
CONTRADICTORY, INCONSISTENT.
AND SO SCHIZOPHRENIC YOU WILL
GET WHIPLASH.
IT'S ALMOST A GARBAGE DOCUMENT
LIKE THE DOSSIER.
WHAT IS FRUSTRATING ABOUT IT
MOST OF ALL ARE THE THINGS HE
DOESN'T LOOK INTO.
IF HE IS LOOKING INTO RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE HOW CAN YOU NOT
LOOK INTO HILLARY CLINTON
PAYING FOR RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION.
>> Dan: EXACTLY.
>> TO INTERFERE IN THE
ELECTION.
THERE IS NONE OF THAT IN
THERE.
OR THE DOSSIER.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THERE
ABOUT ELTON
ABOUT GLTON
ABOUT GLEON
ABOUT GLENN SIMPSON AND FUSION
G.P.S., ALL OF THEM TRYING TO
INTERFERE BY SPREADING RUSSIAN
INFORMATION.
>> Dan: SARA YOU HAVE BEEN
ON THIS CASE LIKE WHITE ON
RICE.
ONE THING THAT BOTHERS ME IS
THE INITIAL CHARTER WAS TO
INVESTIGATE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN THE ELECTION.
AND IT'S CONVENIENT HE GOES
THROUGH THE MULTIPLE PAGES TO
TALK ABOUT THE DON TRUMP JR.
TOWER MEETING WITH THE
RUSSIANS BUT HE FAILS TO
MENTION THAT THE RUSSIAN
LAWYER WAS WORKING FOR COMPANY
HIRED BY HILLARY CLINTON.
DON'T YOU THINK IT IS A KEY
POINT TO BRING UP?
>> IT'S A HUGE POINT.
SO HERE YOU HAVE A NATALIA
VESELNITSKAYA.
SHE MEETS WITH GLENN SIMPSON
OF FUSION GPS THE DAY BEFORE
AND THE DAY AFTER.
THE DAY AFTER THAT MEETING AND
SIMPSON IS LIKE NO, WE DIDN'T
DISCUSS THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETING AT ALL.
SO THESE ARE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ANSWERED.
LET ME TELL YOU, DAN.
THE BIGGEST POINT HERE IS WE
HEAR RUMORS ABOUT WHAT ROBERT
MUELLER WILL BE TESTIFYING
ABOUT AND HOW THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT ON THE PART OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS TOTAL THEATER ON THE
PART OF THE DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONTINUOUSLY,
INCLUDING ANDREW McCABE, WHO
HAS BEEN ON MSNBC OVER AND
OVER AGAIN, WHO WAS BASICALLY
THROWN OUT OF THE F.B.I. FOR
LYING AND FIRED BY THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
FOR BEING A LIAR.
AND THE I.G. CAUGHT HIM LYING
MULTIPLE TIMES AND LEAKING
INFORMATION TO THE MEDIA.
THIS IS HOW THEY ARE TRYING TO
KEEP DISINFORMATION ALIVE.
BY HOLDING A HEARING WHICH IS
THEATRICAL.
AND ROBERT MUELLER CAN'T GO
OUTSIDE THE PURVIEW OF HIS
REPORT.
THERE IS QUESTIONS THAT NEED
TO BE ANSWERED.
AS YOU SAID I BELIEVE THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE THE UPPER
HAND HERE.
THEY ASK HIM QUESTIONS THAT
ARE VERY IMPORTANT, THAT HE
CAN ANSWER.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT HE
CAN'T.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING
TO KEEP THE RUMOR ALIVE.
IT'S A RUMOR AND IT'S A LIE.
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING OTHERWISE
THEY WOULD HAVE USED IT.
>> Dan: THANKS TO PEOPLE
LIKE YOU WE KNOW IT'S LIES.
GREAT WORK.
YOU, TOO, GREGG.
CONGRESSMAN BIGGS, YOU ARE UP
ON THE HILL.
ARE THEY COMMITTED TO GET
ANSWERS FROM BOB MUELLER?
SOMETHING THAT BOTHERS ME IS
NOT THAT HE LEAVES OUT THE
$500,000 PATIENT TO BILL
CLINTON, THAT IS NOT IN THERE.
BUT ALSO ON THE EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE.
TRUMP SAID HE WANTED HIM TO
INVESTIGATE PEOPLE ON THE TEAM
WHO MAY HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
THIS, DOES IT SOUND
OBSTRUCTION TO YOU?
THAT IS NOT IN THE REPORT BY
THE WAY.
>> NO.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
OBSTRUCTION.
IN FACT THERE WASN'T ANY
MR. MUELLER KNEW IT BUT HIS
TEAM WAS RADICALIZED.
DON'T FORGET HE HAD A RADICAL
TEAM THAT CONDUCTED THE
INVESTIGATION.
THEY COME OUT AND I DON'T KNOW
ROBERT MUELLER FROM ADAM BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THIS THE REALITY
IS MR. MUELLER PUT OUT A
REPORT THAT IS NOT A LEGAL
BRIEF.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT AT
ALL.
BUT IT'S AN OPINION PIECE.
THIS IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE THE
HOPE HICKS INTERVIEW.
YOU HAD THE DEMOCRATS READING
OR ASKING HER TO READ.
DIRECT QUOTES FROM THE MUELLER
REPORT.
HOPE HICKS SAY THAT WAS MY
STATEMENT.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WILL GET.
GO TO MUELLER.
YOU WON'T GET ANYTHING NEW
FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
NADLER SAID, CHAIRMAN NADLER
ALREADY SAID HEY, WE WILL
PROBABLY HAVE HIM JUST READ
THINGS.
THIS IS DESIGNED TO KEEP UP
THEIR NARRATIVE OF SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED THAT THERE WAS
AN OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
SOMEHOW JUST LIKE YOU HEARD IN
THE DEBATE LAST NIGHT, SOMEHOW
THE PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF
SOMETHING.
THERE IS NOTHING HERE.
THEY KNOW IT.
THEY CAN'T GET HIM ON ANYTHING
THAT IS CRIMINAL SO THEY WILL
ATTACK AND TRY TO SULLY HIS
NAME WITH THE CONSISTENT
RUMORS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
PUTTING OUT FROM DAY ONE.
>> Dan: GREGG, ONE OF THE
KEY QUESTIONS TO ASK BOB
MUELLER IS WHEN EXACTLY DID
YOU FIND OUT THIS COLLUSION
WAS A HOAX?
WEISSMAN, HIS PITBULL AS THEY
CALL HIM, HE KNEW IN 2016 THAT
THE DOSSIER HAD SERIOUS
ISSUES.
WHEN DID MUELLER FIND THAT
OUT?
>> WITHIN MONTHS OF HIS
APPOINTMENT.
MAY 17, 201.
IN FACT, JOHN DOWD, THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER PLACES IT
AROUND NOVEMBER/DECEMBER OF
2017.
THERE WAS A MEETING ON MARCH
5, 2018.
A FULL YEAR BEFORE THE REPORT
COMES OUT.
IN WHICH ACCORDING TO DOWD,
MUELLER ADMITS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS NO CRIMINAL
EXPOSURE OVER COLLUSION.
MR. MUELLER, WHY DIDN'T YOU
ISSUE AN INTERIM REPORT?
ISN'T IT TRUE YOU WANTED TO
KEEP THIS GOING TO INFLUENCE
UNDULY THE 2018 INTERIM
ELECTIONS?
SO THAT DEMOCRATS COULD TAKE
OVER THE HOUSE?
THAT IS A LEGITIMATE QUESTION
TO ASK.
ALSO, YOU KNOW, MUELLER
INTERVIEWED WITH THE PRESIDENT
THE DAY BEFORE HE TOOK THE JOB
AS SPECIAL COUNSEL, SITTING IN
THE OVAL OFFICE.
ISN'T IT TRUE, MR. MUELLER,
YOU AND THE PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
DISCUSSED THE REASON THAT
COMEY WAS FIRED WHICH MAKES
YOU A WITNESS IN OUR OWN CASE
ON THE OBSTRUCTION
INVESTIGATION?
>> Dan: SARA IS THE CAVALECK
IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT WHERE
SHE MEETS WITH THE DOSSIER IN
INTERVIEW AND THE INFORMATION
IS ALL GARBAGE, IS THAT GOING
TO COME INTO PLAY IN THE
MUELLER HEARING?
THAT INFORMATION SHE TOOK
NOTES ON IT AND IT'S ALL
DISCREDITED.
DO YOU THINK IT COMES UP AT
ALL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS WILL
SWOOP IN ON THAT AND ASK
QUESTIONS ON THAT.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPORTANT.
THOSE E-MAILS AND THOSE
EXCHANGES AND VICTORIA NEWLAND
WHERE THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
WHAT SHE KNEW ARE GOING TO
COME UP BECAUSE AT THAT POINT
IN TIME EVERYBODY KNEW.
THEY QUESTIONED THE DOSSIER
FED TO US BASICALLY BY A
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
FROM MI-6, CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
WHO TOOK A TON OF THIS
INFORMATION FROM THE RUSSIANS.
AND NOW WHAT WE'RE DISCOVERING
IS PEOPLE LIKE JOSEPH MISTOV MAS
IS PEOPLE LIKE JOSEPH MISTOV MAU
IS PEOPLE LIKE JOSEPH MISTOV MAD
WORKING WITH THEM AND SO WE
NEED TO ASK JOHN BRENNAN.
WHAT DID YOU KNOW?
HOW WERE YOU INVOLVED IN THIS?
WHERE DID THE INVESTIGATION
BEGIN?
>> Dan: BRENNAN IS IN A
WORLD OF TROUBLE.
THE GANG OF EIGHT BRIEFING HE
GAVE, REMEMBER, THERE WERE
NOTES ON THAT.
THAT INFORMATION WAS ONLY FROM